and we have ignition the next talk of
the afternoon is by Antoine motive
Thanks I would like first to think to
thank the organizers it really means a
lot for me to be invited here so thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
come this talk is going to be about a
constraint satisfaction so the usual
decision problem side of the other thing
and and to make symmetry come into play
I don't want to take lebos point of view
that only polymorphisms matter but yeah
I want you to bring automorphisms in so
i will talk about infinite domain
concern satisfaction okay so more or
less that the general goal is to find
general conditions abstract conditions
for the tractability of decision
problems and so i want to focus on
infinite domain GSP's because in the
finite so the case is more or less
closed and if possible we want decidable
conditions so we want that given a
description of the problem there is an
algorithm that decides whether the
problem is in PR not and we also want to
prove a complete complete complexity
classification as in the finite so sum
theorem of this form so if we assume
that that the the finite domain
conjecture has been solved then if we
take your village a relational structure
such that all of its relations are
definable in a unary language then the
CSP is NP NP complete so we want to find
complexity dichotomies between P and NP
completeness
alright
so you've got this infinite structure a
where with relations and you want that
the relations or definable in first
order logic using only unary relations
okay this is a toy example so the
outline of the talk is going to be as
follows i will first redefine csps even
though i bought did a great job at
defining them but i will show that some
weird things can happen if you lock the
domain to be infinite and i want to talk
about symmetry and automorphisms vehicle
nickel functions and then we will go
back to to the computer computational
side and and see what we can do using
canonical functions for the complexity
of the CSP ok let's go so we fix a
relational structure with finally many
relations here I do not insist that the
domain is finite a whole morphism
between two structures that have the
same signature is just a function from
the domain of a to the domain of B so
that whenever some trouble it is in some
relation of a then the image of the
toefl component wise is in the
corresponding relation of B and the
constraint satisfaction problem of some
given structure a is the following
decision problem the input is a finite
structure with the same signature and we
want to decide whether there exists a
home off isn't from the finite structure
to to a yes or no so it's a decision
problem of course I think you're a very
familiar with this particular CSP so the
CSP of the triangle graph so it's easy
to see that finite graph Maps homophily
to to the triangle if and only if it's
three colorable and ok it's it's very
well known that this is an np-complete
problem and ok we can have a look at a
CSP of an infant structure so the input
so we have one binary relation here
which is not mr.
which is not symmetric so the input here
is a digraph okay so if a digraph maps
to Z with the order then it's easy to
see that there is no directed cycle in
the finite graph but the converse also
holds rightly if there is no directed
cycle in B then you can complete the
edge relation by your total order which
will map intake structure so the
question is whether this graph is
acyclic and this can be solved in linear
time it gets weirder so if we take the
CSP of this relational structure so it
has to China relations so we see the
operations as relations even though some
people don't like it so the inputs here
is an anchor graph with two type of eye
pro hedges there is hyper edges of the
form e plus and I / edges of the form e
times and here the question is whether
we can map the vertices of this hyper
graph to Z so that whenever we have some
I / edge in a plus we have these
conditions this condition that's
satisfied and whenever an eye / edges in
e times we want that this is satisfied
this is actually a famous problem its
elbows tense problem and it's
undecidable so this is a consequence of
this celebrated result of Matthias a
[ __ ] we will who built upon previous
work that actually every computer in
your animal and your innumerable sets
subset of the integers can be described
with such an instance of the problem
okay so in in contrast with the finite
case for the csbs we can have
undecidable constraint satisfaction
problems but let's focus on the finite
case for a minute so it was conjectured
in the early 90s that if you fix a
finite structure the CSP of this
structure is in p or i'll be complete
this conjecture has been confirmed in
many cases so for for undirected graphs
and then for smooth diagraphs by libra
and for small structures so the
particular value of small tends to
change a lot these times so it was small
equals 2 for a while and then untie
blood off show that it it was true for
three and then geometric extended up to
seven I think the latest results yeah
okay and maybe you even have even has
proof of the conjecture okay and the
stronger version of this conjecture is
that we can actually describe which CSVs
or NP and which SP don't be complete
this is done by polymorphisms so I don't
want to redefine what a polymorphism is
we don't really care so the tractability
conjecture says that if a has a
commutative polymorphism where
commutative where this polymorphism can
have arbitrary finite charity then the
CSP is in p okay and now we want to make
the transition to infinite domain GSP's
so we cannot just look at arbitrary
infinite structures because we saw that
there are undesirable CSPs so it's kind
of unreasonable to just look at
arbitrary internet structures so we want
to find a reasonable class of infant
structures such that there is some hope
of classifying the complexity of all the
cSPD
those stretches this is likely to be at
least as hard as doing the
classification for the finite case so we
are assuming that the truck tractability
conjecture has been solved so now I want
to describe what this reasonable class
of structure is libro mentioned it this
morning so we say that the structure is
finally bounded if you can describe the
set of its finite sub structures in
finite words so we want that there exist
two finite family of abstractions so
that C is a sub structure of our initial
structure be if and only if she does not
contain one of the abstractions so when
B is a finitely bounded structure the
this question the substructure problem
becomes decidable so to decide the
question whether see is a substructure
of B we can just have a look at which
are the substructures of C and then this
answers the question by the by this
property yeah c is finite yeah
examples of fancy bounded structure so
you can have a look at the rational
order where you can see that every
finite structure of this is that in your
order and conversely any final structure
which is a linear other embeds into this
so the abstractions are all the three
elements structures that are not linear
orders where does the three comes from
it's because being a linear order is a
first order property and you can express
this property with 3 by ovals so this is
this is general whenever you have a
property that is first order definable
with finitely many axioms you just look
at the number of variables you need to
define this and this gives you a set of
abstractions with this given with this
size as we structures of this size sorry
Yuri Winx rocket yeah protection Phoenix
universal universal did I safest hola ok
you know so you know so it's odd yeah
another example an interesting one is
the universal triangle free graph so
here again you can say that a graph does
not contain triangle with universal
sentence with three variables so this
gives us this abstraction
okay and the second property that we
need for this reasonable class of fire
structures is homogeneity so this comes
from model theory we say that the
structure is homogeneous if whenever too
small to finite sub structures or look
identical there is actually a symmetry
of the structure that takes the first
one to the other
okay there is also the notion of redact
so this word has been overloaded with
time so for me a redact so we have a
structure beer and the real act of B is
just a structure a on which lives on the
same domain and whose relations are
definable using first-order logic in the
in the relations of B so an example for
example if we take be to be the the
Russian or order a classical example of
a reductive the between this relation
and the conjecture of boyarsky and ping
and Pinsker it is the following so you
take a a structure which is a real act
of a finitely bounded homogeneous
structure then the CSP of this structure
is going to be in Pierre NP complete so
this might look a bit weird yes you mean
faster the definition of the quantifier
free is going to be the same because of
homogeneity you have quantified
relations or distressing
so yeah why this hypothesis and not
something else so what's nice is that we
have omega two categorical structures so
that so I think could I talked about
this on the first day so the
automorphism group of those structures
is very nice it has only finitely many
orbits on elements and pairs on triples
and so on the second property that we
have here is that the CSP is always in
NP and this follows from the fact that
the substructure problem is in NP and in
fact this conjecture is false if we drop
the finite boundedness assumption and
it's false for a very stupid reason is
that we can find and constantly many
structures which are homogeneous and
their only contact we many algorithms so
one of them has to be undecidable so
this is the class of interest and yeah i
think this conjecture is more or less
widely believed to be true but the
question of course is how how do we plan
to prove it and so again if you look at
the class of all the finite domain CSP
they they fall into this budget skip an
integer class so the real question is
how to prove it assuming that the finite
domain conjecture is true so as in the
finite case look at the Nazi the
financier Azad yeah so for each finite
domain CSP you can find a structure here
which has the same CSP so they have the
same yes instances so that proving this
with in particular prove the affiant
event conjecture
fits in okay it's not obvious but so
look you take as domain the natural
numbers and you have one constant for
each element of your finite dimensions p
and then you can encode the relations of
your financial NTSB on this structure
which is infinite and this is a reductio
finally bounded homogeneous structure
other questions okay is this a subject
of finite finally badness can you is it
a parent to having like some sort of
actually mitch's like a pie to execute
ization or something any muscle yeah
finite union affects my
ok so the conjecture has been proven in
quite a number of cases so these are
some special cases so just take the most
stupid infa instructor you can think of
just a concept infinite domain with
equality and all the relations that you
can first holiday fine overrides then
here there is a complexity dichotomy
this has been extended to the real acts
of the radiograph and then to the Redux
of any homogeneous graph this is very
recent and we also have a complexity
classification for the Redax of the
rational order and in fact in the first
three cases the classification is is
taking the following form so we have to
look at the so-called canonical
polymorphisms of our structure a and
whenever we have a good canonical
polymorphism the CSP is in P and
otherwise it's NP complete and this is
not true for for q4 for the rational
other so I want to now explain what this
canonical means so let me just recall
some some notions that we have seen
earlier we fix a permutation group on on
the set X so the group is G the orbit of
an M topple is just the set of n tuples
that you can obtained by applying one
single function from the group we say
that a group is a legal morphic if four
elements pears and apples and so on it
has only finitely many orbits so this
corresponds to automorphism groups of
Omega categorical structures
a function clone it's a set of finite
area operation on the set which is
closed under this composition and that
contains the dictators okay and so there
is something that we don't see in the
finite case is that whenever you look at
these objects there is a natural
topology which is the topology of point
west convergence so a sequence a
sequence of functions converges to to a
given function f if for arbitrarily
large finite sets these functions tend
to agree with F so on the finite of
course this means that this sequence is
eventually concerned but on the infinite
that makes a difference and so since we
have a topology we can talk about
continuous maps between between clones
okay and continually means that to know
whether two functions have the same
image you only have to look at some
finite subset of X and if they if the
two functions agree on this finite
subset then they have this image okay so
now i can i can give you the definition
of canonical function so we fix a group
acting on X and some function a some
operation a finite aarati on X and we
say that this function is canonical if
this holds so this means that whenever
you plug in elements from G into f as
parameters you can find on every finite
subset an element of G so that it's the
same as applying alpha 1 to alpha and on
the inside or as applying this new
element on the outside so this might be
a bit technical an equivalent definition
would be to say that F not only is an
operation on X but it also is an
operation on all the orbits of em
suppose under the action of G
so in particular when G is illegal
morphic then F acts on finite sets and
this gives us the connection with the
final two in GSP's and we have this
theorem of bodies keeping sky and two
dots on curve which says that for
sufficiently nice groups G whenever you
pick a function you can find another
function in its neighborhood that will
be canonical so this canonical functions
seem to be everywhere and sometimes they
are even enough to talk about complexity
and we can remarked that if you compose
canonical functions together your tenure
canonical function so you obtain your
clone some it might be useful to look at
an example now so if we if we look at
the the rational order the unary
functions are just the monotone function
so I use this notation for unary
functions so here you look at the orbit
so the function f induces an action on
the orbit so we look at orbits of pairs
of which there are three and the disk
group and the function can either be
increasing decreasing or constant and
essentially there are only three
canonical functions in this case for
binary functions we use this notation so
this is the first argument of the
function which is now still in orbit
this is the second argument and this
function defined some kind of
lexicographic order so you see that the
function looks at what's the first
argument and it replies with the same
order if the if the first orbit is not
on the diagonal and if the orbit is on
the diagonal you you start to look at
the second argument and reply with the
same so this function which is binary we
can it induces another on Q which looks
like this Morris
computer punkish crap yeah
so okay a nun example of canonical
function is the maximum fraction so this
is not canonical because the maximum
function does not behave in the same way
depending on where you look so if you
look far to the left of the main
diagonal this function tends to look
like the first projection and if you
look far above the main diagonal it
tends to look like the second projection
okay a central concept about chemical
functions is the following so if we fix
GNH to be canonical functions the
mash-up of these two functions is any
canonical function which satisfies this
so we fix gh and to orbit and we are
taking a mash-up of GH over these two
orbits so with the notation that I used
in the previous slide we have so we have
orbit here and here and we just want a
function that looks like G here and H
here so we somehow glue GNH together and
we don't care what happens otherwise so
maybe i will skip this so there is this
notion of homo films between clone so
these are functions that preserve
equations they are very important
because whenever these Homo films are
continuous you can say you can use them
to say something about the complexity of
the CSP I don't have time for this
what we can prove that if you take a a
clone on the on which contains a naruto
morphic group and such that whenever you
have two functions in the clone you can
find a mash-up of these two functions
which is again in the chrome then we
have with binary functions the shuttle
now you can generalize it to two hours
ya know for every pair of function you
you need that there exists a mash-up you
don't need that all of them are in the
club so we have the following either
there is a continuous map from C to the
crown of projection so this is a very
important clone this is the chrome that
represents np-hardness for CSP so this
is the crown of polymorphisms of three
sets so we have a continuous map like
that we can even drop continually for
the mat and this is where it gets
interesting we can prove that this is
equivalent to having a a map from the
clone of canonical functions that are in
C to the projections these are negative
statements in the I mean so these are
positive statements that prove somehow
NP hardness of the CSP and we can prove
that these positive statements or
equivalent to these negative statements
which is the non-existence of a pseudo
cyclic operation so in the finite we had
cyclic operations to witness
tractability and in this case we have
pseudo cyclic operations so a pseudo
cyclic operation is just like a cyclic
operation accepts that you have to
compose with unary operations here on
the outside and what's good is that
since we can look at canonical functions
of which there are only finally many
essentially any of these properties is
decidable so now let's have a look at
how to use this for for the study of
CSPs
so this is a result of last legs if if
we assume that the tractability
conjecture is true if we take a rib
structure a which is in the body
skipping Pinsker class either a as a
pseudo cyclic polymorphism which is
canonical and this is p is in p or its
NP hard and oh sorry sorry so if a as a
pseudo cyclic polymorphism we can prove
that the cs pigeon pea and in fact so
here i used pseudo cyclic but we can
take any condition from the finite case
such as multi that the ball presented
this morning and lift it for for the
body skipping school class okay and this
is somewhat new if we assume the
tractability conjecture and we take a
structure such that the polymorphisms
have mashups then we have a dichotomy
between NP completeness and tracks
ability and this is witnessed by
Canonical's to those i click operations
and this this means that if the
tractability conjecture is true for all
those structures that have mashups the
membership in p is decidable
okay so i said earlier that canonical
functions were not always enough so
these bubbles here we present the
classes of structures for which we can
improve complexity classifications only
using canonical functions and I also
said that for Q it was not true so we
know that this method will fail at some
point for for the body sleeping scare
class what's not clear now is what's the
boundary between when it's youthful and
when it's not and these are examples for
for which it seems that that the method
will work yeah this is my final slide
thank you we have time for some
questions ok so I rather by missed it
but do you feel explicitly that these if
you guys have mashups it flows so I can
I can prove it for here here and here
now for the other for this one it's no
it's rather tricky I think it's true
it's essentially decidable so you could
check it with the count with a computer
I just didn't do it right I think I have
no control example so it's possible that
here you have measured ok but I see but
there's still that discrepancy
it could be that canonical functions are
enough to witness tractability but
without having this measure property it
could be but you can ject you that that
doesn't happen yeah I do not contact out
that
any other questions thank you